اعتقد انه هذا عمليا يعني يفكك الدعم
السريع
تجاوزت مساله الدمج التي كانت تتحدث عنها
سابقا فبالتالي الان حملتيه هو
يخسر من خلال
استراتيجيه قوات المسلحه عسكريا ولا
سياسيا ايضا
هكذا يبدو لي الامر من خلال ما اراه ولكن
استاذ عادل انا اريد ان اعلق على هذه
الصوره التي نراها الان على شاشه العربيه
وانت يعني لك التجربه في الخرطوم من قبل
ان شاء الله نزورها مره اخرى وهي اهدا من
مما نشاهده افضل مما نشاهده ان شاء الله
تفضل
فانا يعني اريد ان اوضح بان هذا الامر هو
تقريبا في اتجاه الخرطوم هذه هذه السحابه
لانها هي في ذات الشارع والمسار الذي يقود
من مكاتب قناه العربيه الحدث الشرقا حتى
الجهاده من المخابرات حتى الطب الحديث
يمين نحو المطار
مباشره سكن حميتي ثم من من
سكن البرهان فبالتالي اعتقد ان الان هناك
فيما يبدو دهانات ضربت خزانات الوقود التي
هي تجعل مثل هذا هذا الامر بكثافه بجانب
ايضا اتوقع انه تم من خلال دهانات قد تكون
بعض المباني تعرضت للحرق مما زاد من
اجتهال هذه
النيران التي لا نراها ولكن نرى سحب
الدخان هذا جمله يعني ان هذا اليوم سيكون
يوم عسير وعصيب على الخرطوم وعلى الطرفين
المتسارعين القوات المسلحه
وتالي هذا يعزز فرديه سقوط عدد كبير من
القتلى والجرحى لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات